hello
the title of this talk is mixing in
non-quasi random groups
my name is emmanuel viola and this is
joint work with timothy hours
this work is about products in groups
and this topic and our results in
particular
can be presented and approached from two
points of view which are really two
sides of the same coin
one is communication complexity
and the other one is mixing
this being a computer science conference
we're going to start with the
communication complexity viewpoint
in this talk
i'm going to focus on the results in the
paper
however this area has connections
uh the good beyond our results
in particular to uh some long-standing
challenges
in communication complexity and i just
want to to point you to this survey here
which is on my homepage
if you want to find out more about these
connections and other aspects of this
area
but for now we're going to focus on some
very concrete
problems and as a warm-up
let us consider the problem
in which you have a finite group g
you should think of g as being finite
but large so all the results in this
group in this stock
we're going are going to be asymptotic
with the size of the group
and you have two parties alice and bob
and each party receives an input so
alice receives x
and bob receives y
and their goal is to decide
if the product the product of x and y is
equal to one
and they're allowed to use randomness
so this warm up case as a very simple
solution
bob can compute in his head
the inverse of y with no communication
and then the parties can simply check if
x times y is equal to 1
by checking if x is equal to y inverse
which can be done with constant
communication using the protocol for
equality
things get more interesting if you have
three parties and this is the focus of
this work
so now we have alice bob and chloe
and they each receive an input and we
work in the basic number in hand model
so alice
knows x her input
bob knows y and chloe knows z
and again they want to decide if x times
y times z
is equal to 1.
now the communication complexity here
depends on the group g
if the group is a billion
then it can be shown that the
communication is
constant
this result can be generalized to the
case in which the group is almost a
billion
and almost a billion
is defined
to mean that the group has in a billion
sub group of constant index
so
a question that i want to
highlight
is whether this implication here can be
also reversed
is it true that the communication is
constant if and only if the group is
almost a billion
we don't know how to prove it and
it seems that it's an interesting
question it would be a nice
characterization of almost a billion
groups
moving forward there is another class of
groups
which is known as quasi random and that
was introduced by gowers
and for these groups the communication
is large okay how large depends on how
was random the group is but you can
think of it as being a growing function
so in this work we're going to consider
groups which are in between quasi-random
and almost a billion we're going to
study this communication problem in
those groups
let me give you some examples of such
in-between groups
the first example is the
affine group
that's the group of two by two matrices
which have entries a1 a2
0 and a1
where a1 and the 2 are in the finite
field with q elements and a1 is not 0.
okay
again this group is
neither almost a billion
nor quasi random
the other two examples are
natural generalizations
of
the group there is perhaps dearest to
computer science which is the hypercube
with bitwise
addition
so the first generalization is the
so-called
finite lamp lighter group
which can be expressed
as a z2 wreath product zn
more concretely the elements of the
group are n bits x1 x2 dot dot xn
and a shift s which is an element of the
zn
okay and you can think of the elements
as corresponding to n lamps and each
lamp can be on or off
and the shift s corresponds to
the position of the lamp lighter
who's in the process of switching the
lamps if you want to multiply an element
like the one we described by another
element you do as follows first you
shift the bits x i's by s you just
rotate them by s and then you sum
coordinate wise
okay
the third and final example of in
between groups
is
that of product groups g
of the type h to the n where h is not a
billion
think for example h
has constant size
okay so again this is a generalization
of the hypercube which corresponds to h
just being
z2
so a main result in this paper is
lower bounds
and some upper bounds
for the communication complexity of
deciding if x times y times z is equal
to 1 in these groups
so if the group is a fine
is defined group then we get
that the communication complexity is
theta
log the size of the group so here we get
matching lower and upper bounds
if the group is the lamp lighter group
then we also get matching lower
and upper
bounds and now the bounds are of the
form theta log log the size of the group
if you have a product group
h to the n
where h is constant and h is not a
billion then we prove that the
communication complexity is always at
least omega log n
and here
an open question is whether this bound
can be strengthened to theta of n
and now i can turn it to the viewpoint
of mixing
so different types of groups uh mix in a
different ways
so
there are those groups which do not mix
and for example almost a billion groups
are such groups
what do i mean by not don't mix i mean
that you can find
two distributions x and y
over the group
which are independent
and have high entropy
but if you multiply the distributions
which means you sample from x and you
sample from y up with the product
you get something which is very far from
uniform so it does not mix too uniform
and here
and later by high entropy you can just
think for example that each distribution
is uniform over a constant fraction of
the group okay so again in this case you
can find the two distributions which are
independent high entropy over the group
but if you multiply them they don't mix
they don't approach the uniform
distribution over the group
at the other end of the spectrum you
have quasi-random groups
and here for every distribution x and y
as above it turns out that x times y
does become close to uniform
in this work and next
we are going to consider in between
groups
uh
these are groups where for every x and y
as above
x times y doesn't necessarily get close
to uniform but still it gets a little
closer to uniform
and a main conceptual contribution on
this work
is what do we mean by closer to uniform
and specifically we introduce a new
definition of mixing
we say that a group g mixes via a
distribution of functions f from the
group to the group if the following
holds
first of all this distribution should
not be trivial which means that for
every x it is unlikely that f of x is
equal to x
and second for every distributions x and
y as before so they are independent high
entropy distributions of the group
the distributions
x and y
and the distribution f
of x and y are close in statistical
distance
in other words when you multiply x and y
you get two distribution which is
invariant under f it does not change
much if you apply f
and this is intuitively making the
distribution closer to uniform because
of course the uniform
the uniform distribution would be
invariant
under any f
a main motivation for this definition is
that it is sufficient for the
communication complexity lower bounds
okay so what can we show well uh we can
show again that almost a billion groups
don't mix
even in this sense
on the other hand if the group g is
quasi random
you do mix and in fact you can take f to
be a random function
and in our case for our groups in
between
you can get some f which are
non-trivial although they're not
completely
random
let's see the examples
so in the example of defined group
which again
was the group of two by two minutes
um with entries a1a201
then you can mix as follows
you can define f that given a matrix
sets the top right coordinate to a
uniform element in the field
okay so given any element from the group
f just replaces the top right entry with
a uniform element from the field and
this actually turns out to be the
strongest possible mixing that you can
have because you cannot change
the entry x1
the second example was the finite length
by the group which i remind you consists
of elements
with n bits and the shift s
and here the mixing
depends
on the prime factorization of n
for simplicity i'm going to consider
that n is prime
in this case
you can mix in the following
way
given
an element
consisting of n bits and a shift
s
you can mix by replacing the bits
with a uniform selection of bits which
have the same parity so you can replace
the x's with y's as long as they have
the same parity
and this again is the strongest possible
mixing because it can be shown that you
cannot
change the parity of the axis or the
shift s
finally we get to the setting of product
groups
and here again i remind you that the
mixing
no here sorry these were groups
of the type h2 to the n where h is not a
billion
and you can think of it as being a
constant size
and here the mixing is achieved
by selecting a uniform coordinate i
and setting that uniform
coordinated to a uniform conjugate okay
so given a tuple of elements from h you
pick a random
element in the tuple and you set it
to uniform conjugate
in fact under a condition on h you can
set that a uniform element
to a
to just a uniform element from u
you can set h i to u but in general for
elements for h
which are not
a billion you can only take a conjugate
and here actually the error of this
mixing is just one over n
uh what conceivably could be you can
have a mixing which is much smaller
error
and this error is somewhat inherent
because
in our
approach because it comes
from the choice of i
which could
be a bad coordinate with probability one
over n
and the question that i asked at the
beginning of this talk
can be now be phrased as follows
is it true that the g mixes if and only
if it is not almost a billion
in other words if the group does not
have a in a billion subgroup of constant
index
okay now i'm going to spend a little bit
of time explaining how we prove
mixing and unsurprisingly
we rely on non-obedient foreign artists
also known as representation theory
so in brief
if you have
any function f from the group to the
complex
numbers
you have an inversion formula which says
that f of x the value of f at any point
x
can be written as the sum over raw where
raw arranges over irreducible
representations
which will abbreviate e-reps
e-reps
of the dimension of raw so rho is a
matrix of dimension d rho times 0
times the trace
of the fourier coefficient of f at rho
times rho x transpose
and the fourier coefficient is the
expectation of f of x
times the conjugate of rho x
okay
so
at a high level you're writing f of x
as
as a weighted
sum
of the real coefficients
where the weights
are the
dimensions of the
reps and every group has a trivial rep
of dimension one
and if you exclude that the dimension of
the other reps
uh characterize interesting families of
groups almost a billion groups
are those groups which have erupts of
bounded dimension
all
dimensions are constant quasi-random
groups
have
all dimensions
which are large you can think of them as
being growing and our in-between groups
are mixed right some dimensions are
small but some dimensions are large
to prove our results
we establish a lemma that says that if x
and y
are independent distributions
over the group
then you can approximate the product
distribution x y
by e reps which have low dimensions okay
you can truncate
the fourier expansion of x and y
by keeping just
the reps which have low dimension
and then we show two ways in which this
lemma can be used
one way is the so-called kernel method
we show that if you have an element in
the group which is in the kernel of
every rep
of
small dimension
then you can mix simply by
multiplying an element of the group by h
so f of g is just the deterministic
function which multiplies by h
and again the idea is that because h is
in the kernel
of every low dimension a rep and since
you can only you can approximate x y
with the reps of load dimension
uh multiplying by h does not change x y
this method works for a find in the
lamplighter group and
this can be verified that just by
looking
uh the reps of these of these groups but
it does not work for product groups
for product groups we do something
different
still relying on the
dilemma
the basic observation is that the e-reps
in product groups h to the n
are tensors
of the e-reps of h
and in particular the dimensions
multiply
so because by the lemma we can
approximate x y
by e reps with low dimensions
we must have that
we can approximate x y
with reps that have dimension
either one
or that that depend on few coordinates
right because if you had many
reps
of the basic group h which have
dimension larger than one
and you tensorize
because the dimensions multiply
you will get a
an rep for h to dn which has very large
dimensions but the lemma allows us to
ignore them
okay so we can approximate x y with the
reps which depend on few coordinates or
possibly have dimension one
now remember that the mixing was
by picking a uniform coordinate i
and then setting that coordinate to a
uniform conjugate
and the basic idea why this works is
that
when you pick a random i
the approximation of x y is unlikely to
depend on i
so whether or not you pick this
conjugate does not change the
distribution
and this concludes
our talk
thank you